[Music]
hold if you wish to enter
identify
the wounded are not recovering at all
hang in there
you'll be well soon enough
thank you oh blessed priest
ah you're here
right this way
follow me
you've come
i was here treating the soldiers
allow me to introduce myself
i am thyrene a knight of luterra
well met sir thyren i am armin
and this is my traveling companion
i wanted to thank you for treating my
soldiers
their slow recovery has weighed heavily
on me
thanks to you i have one less thing to
keep me up at night
you must be exhausted
let me get you a hot meal and some
accommodations for the night
target in sight no witnesses
uh
protect the prince secure the perimeter
prince tyrane are you hurt
nothing
for you to worry about
but your highness
i told you
i'm fine
it's just a scratch if i may please hold
still
to love
impressive
fortunately the wound was not too deep
clearly you're more than just a knight
of luterra
i'm not much of a prince these days
we can talk more about it over there
thank you for your help this could have
been a real disaster
foreign